et je demande à chacun de se calmer et
je donne la parole à monsieur laurent
wauquiez il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
allez on écoute
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre nous
éprouvons tous aujourd'hui un sentiment
de révolte sur tous les bancs toute la
france est en deuil
il faut se recueillir mais il faut
surtout agir et nous ne serons pas jugé
sur de grands discours mais sur nos
actions allons nous subir ce monde de
terreur pour nos enfants
ça suffit et monsieur le premier
ministre nous n'avons notre propre
attendu il faut se tourner vers demain
mais en ayant tiré les leçons des échecs
d'hier il n'y a plus de place monsieur
le premier ministre pour les 2000 m sur
merà kouassi coulibaly mostefaï ils
étaient tous fichés et leurs dérives
islamistes connus grâce au travail de
nos forces de l'ordre mais ce que
personne ne comprend aujourd'hui c'est
pourquoi ces terroristes en puissance
tapis dans l'ombre prêt à nous frapper
étaient laissés dans la nature il ne
suffit pas de les suivre
il faut les arrêter avant qu'il ne passe
à l'acte même si cela passe par un
changement profond de notre droit tous
les individus en fichier est pour
radicalisation ne peuvent plus être en
liberté
expulsion des étrangers déchéance de
nationalité pour les binationaux mais
aussi et c'est le centre du problème
centres de rétention pour ceux qui sont
nés français sans prendre aujourd'hui le
risque d'attendre l'heure n'est plus aux
arguties juridiques le sujet dès lors
que vous avez décidé de changer la
constitution n'est pas la saisine du
conseil d'état
la question c'est jusqu'où sommes-nous
décidé à les changer la constitution
pour la changer ne servirait à rien
ma question est précise avez vous
l'intention monsieur le premier ministre
à appliquer ce principe de protection
pour arrêter ces terroristes en
puissance avant qu'il ne passe à l'acte
les français veulent des mesures
concrètes ils veulent des mesures
immédiates il faut mettre ces
terroristes en puissance hors d'état de
nuire ainsi il n'y a pas deux comme
c'est le premier ministre vis-à-vis sur
les députés monsieur wauquiez je vais
prendre un peu de temps et vous répondre
le plus précisément possible sur
l'ensemble des propositions qui ont pu
être faites face et vous plaît s'il vous
plaît
face à la menace terroriste est à la
définition des moyens juridiques
exceptionnelle dont nous avons besoin
pour affronter le terrorisme de guerre
nous devons tous
je pense que nous pouvons être d'accord
privilégier l'intérêt national et
l'efficacité concrète et il ne devrait
pas y avoir de place ni pour l'invectivé
ni pour la polémique il est il est
absolument faux de dire que les
propositions de l'opposition n'ont pas
été intégrées dans le travail législatif
conduit ces trois dernières années
et soyons précis et rigoureux
il ya d'abord les dispositions qui
figurait dans le projet de loi élaboré
par gouvernement de françois fillon en
avril 2012
à la suite des crimes commis par mohamed
merah en mars 2012
le renforcement de la répression la
provocation l'apologie du terrorisme
nous avons sorti l'incrimination de la
loi de 1881 sur la presse pour en faire
un délit
autonome dans le code pénal en prévoyant
différents dispositifs judiciaires
l'incrimination la consultation
habituelle de sites internet djihadistes
parce que nous savons que c'est sur
internet que se joue cette
radicalisation
nous l'avons reprise en l'incluant dans
un ensemble plus cohérent et plus sévère
encore nous avons je vous le rappelle
voté de loi antiterroriste
l'une en décembre 2012 où j'avais évoqué
déjà cet ennemi intérieur extérieur
une autre celle de décembre 2014 nous
sommes allés plus loin puisque les sites
sur ce sujet là puisque les sites
provoquant au terrorisme en faisant
l'apologie peuvent désormais être
bloquée et déférence et dans le cadre
administratif à titre préventif et donc
pas seulement à l'initiative d'un
magistrat judiciaire comme vous l'aviez
de proposer en 2012
l'incrimination des axes terroriste
intégralement commis à l'étranger
nous l'avons fait aussi il ya ensuite
aujourd'hui de nouvelles propositions
faites par l'opposition qu'elle n'avait
pas jugé bon de proposer après les
crimes proposé commis par mohamed merah
elles sont de trois ordres
celles qui correspondent à leurs propres
réflexions d'ailleurs et propositions et
sur lesquelles un consensus républicain
est souhaitable
c'est le cas de l'extension des cas où
la déchéance de nationalité est possible
pour les personnes condamnées pour
terrorisme aux personnes nées en france
le président de la république l'a
proposé mais mesdames et messieurs les
députés l'opposition
il faut faire preuve de cohérence une
révision constitutionnelle est
nécessaire pour l'inscrire dans notre
droit
soit vous êtes d'accord et vous voter
cette réforme constitutionnelle soit
vous ne l'êtes pas alors voulaient ma
peau et celle qui méritait d'être
examinée sans a priori mais qui à la
réflexion ne paraissent pas porteuse
d'efficacité opérationnelle dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme
c'est par exemple le cas de la peine dit
dignité nationale rapport parlementaire
a démontré que cette disposition n'était
pas adapté celle qui soulève et c'est
bien normal de sérieuses questions
juridiques pour ne pas tomber dans un
régime d'exception comme celle de placer
sous bracelet électronique ou en
internement d'office toute personne
faisant l'objet d'une fiche est ce même
lorsqu'il n'existe alors en compte que
de simples soupçons
renseignements non recoupées celle ci
celle ci
soulève de graves problèmes de droits
par rapport à la constitution et à nos
obligations internationales dans un
esprit d'unité nationale et constructif
le président de la république a proposé
de les soumettre au conseil d'état
pourquoi pas uniquement pour savoir si
monsieur wauquiez
c'est conforme à la constitution mais
tout simplement pour bien analyser le
rapport de ce type de proposition avec
les conventions internationales
je vous invite à les affiner allait
formuler aller travailler et le
gouvernement est prêt à une discussion
pour intégrer toute proposition qui
efficace et dans le sens de nos propres
accords internationaux nous puissions le
signer l'encadré l'intégrer dans une
réforme constitutionnelle
je vous rappelle que le conseil d'état
avait en effet considéré en 2012 que
cette proposition était disproportionnée
nous sommes prêts à examiner toute
solution enfin je voudrais dire que ce
gouvernement qui est à l'écouté de
l'ensemble de la représentation
nationale n'a pas non plus attendu
l'opposition pour renforcer la
protection des français et la loi sur
l'enseignement en témoigne même si elle
ne concerne pas exclusivement le
terrorisme elle comprend des
dispositions spécifiques vous le savez
au terrorisme le recours aux nouvelles
techniques de renseignement sera
particulièrement utile de même la
création d'une sorte de filature
électronique permanente djihadistes
était vous le savez une nécessité
opérationnel fort et le gouvernement
mettra ces dispositions aux love
dès lors que la proposition loi
actuellement soumise à l'examen du
conseil constitutionnel sera promulguée
monsieur wauquiez
nous sommes ouverts à cette discussion
voulez parler du passé je ne sais pas
sur ça intéresse les français
moi je pourrais vous parler de ceux qui
ont pris la responsabilité de dissoudre
les renseignements généraux
c'est à dire le renseignement
territoriales
moi je pourrais vous parler et ça serait
si facile des treize mille postes de
policiers et de gendarmes qui ont
affaibli l'appareil sécuritaire cela ce
type de débat n'intéresse pas nos
compatriotes monsieur wauquiez ce que
les intéressés nous pouvons nous mettre
d'accord là dessus c'est la sécurité des
frontières et moi je m'engage avec mon
gouvernement et avec la représentation
nationale au sens le plus large possible
de tout faire pour assurer la sécurité
des français
donc si vous voulez discuter notamment
pour une réforme de la constitution
nous sommes prêts pour avancer merci
monsieur leproux